Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'm in the deserts of
Southern Utah and I'm camping in a
snowstorm and searching for ancient
Native American cities
I'm having a great time come along with
a ride it's gonna be awesome
[Music]
I love you guys will you be good for
Mama yeah
I'm going to be doing an 11 and a half
mile hike through a series of canyons
and rumor has it that there's dozens of
untouched ancient Native American
archaeological sites in this Canyon
which we can explore I heard one person
call this hike an open air museum I
gotta admit I'm excited to check this
out this is gonna be cool
it's kind of a surreal experience I'm
sitting here hiking in the bitter cold
with snow around and I'm in the middle
of the desert it's so weird seeing
cactuses and snow at the same time
foreign
s right there
so this is the dwelling homes of the
Anasazi Indians the anasazis would find
these outcroppings under these Cliffs
and they would build their homes here
they'd take this flat stone that's
everywhere and stack it up and put mud
in between it and build homes out of it
they take these Cedar beams and sticks
lay them in a crisscross pattern with
mud over the top there you go you've got
a cozy little home build a fire in here
and that heat would reflect brilliantly
a lot of these structures like this one
were greeneries they would have very
seasonal foods and they would take the
surplus food and preserve it and put it
in here and then they would wall it all
up and they'd just fill this up with
rocks and then the animals couldn't get
to it see they've got a granary back
there one right there
one right here you can see this Granary
is open
but there's this one and this one over
there and there's no entrance so it's
still sealed up yeah who knows what's
inside those things look at this
little piece of pottery right here
that is so cool
this could be a thousand years old I'm
just gonna go ahead and put that right
back
now this looks more like a building
because there's like a window and a door
whoa that's cool
just barely enough room that you could
lay down and build a fire in here which
is really all you'd want to do in the
wintertime
bet In the Heat of the summer this place
feels amazing
wow that looks like a little Shard of
pottery right there that's so cool
it's a little bit of the mortar that's
falling out
look at this log how old it is you know
these pieces of wood have been here for
hundreds of years and they haven't
rotten away
foreign
this is just amazing this has been here
for hundreds of years and nobody's
managed to destroy it or fence It Off
that's pretty cool
this is cool hey look at this look what
I found
this is the center of the Indian corn
cob
look at that
I just leave that right there
pieces of charcoal left over from their
campfires here
that is cool
I keep finding these pieces of chert or
Flint I think this is what they use to
make arrowheads and spearheads and stuff
man it just makes so much sense to build
your house here if you build your house
down on the bottom it's going to flood
every time there's a rainstorm you build
your house to the top you've got the
full sun on you in the summertime and
all the cold wind in the winter well
that was way cool but we've got a lot of
ground to cover and a lot more cool
stuff to explore
foreign
so this right here is a wash or a dried
up River here in the desert these are
usually just bone dry like you see them
now but if it rains even far away these
can turn into a raging Rapids and then
you do not want to be in here if you're
in a really narrow Canyon where your
only choice is to walk in the wash this
can be really dangerous and you got to
watch the weather closely so that you
don't get caught in a flash flood but
luckily this Canyon is pretty Broad and
the sides aren't that steep so I can get
out if I need to
look at this oh we got a little rodent
Prince here we got some sort of small
cat not seeing any claws in the print
oh here's another one of those granaries
you see a pack rats made its home you
see all the little pack rat poops check
it out you can see more pack rat nests
they just gather up everything they can
and shove it up into these cracks all
right I better keep moving I got a lot
more to see a lot of ground to cover
between the Slick Rock and the snow
finding a trail here is a little bit
challenging luckily I know I'm supposed
to head downhill in the bottom of this
Canyon so I can't get too lost
I was worried I wouldn't see any water
on the trail so far there's been plenty
in the summertime finding water in these
Canyons is really hit and miss
foreign
oh look at that view that's pretty
oh sitting here doing my snack breaking
I think I see another set of ruins up
there
let me see if I can get better look
a little bit of something was built here
this is some of that dried mud here this
is a little bit of dried mud right there
thank you looks like there's some
structures up there maybe but I don't
want to break my neck to get up there
plus I got a lot of miles to cover yet
if you spend enough time in this Canyon
you're going to just find stuff that
nobody else has found
oh
I'm taking out the Canyon goes over that
direction but we got a little peekaboo
window into the next Canyon over
if you look way over there to that Cliff
just right on this little ledge you can
see more ruins right up there
how on Earth did they get up there they
must have had some crazy ladders
check it out right up there in the Rocks
I can see another structure
somebody put this rock here and packed
all this mudder on it and smeared the
mud with their fingertips a thousand
years ago
oh yeah that is so cool here's another
chunk of mud with the rock sticking out
of it I mean somebody had to haul all
that mud and food up here to make this
Granary
this is insane I mean look at this
big Granary right there
whose idea was it to build up here
nobody's gonna casually walk off with
your food though you gotta get down
without killing myself
and I keep stopping and exploring every
few minutes it's making things go a
little bit slow I need to pick up the
pace
oh that's Steve
having all this gear on my back doesn't
make this easier on my quads oh
I take it out we got a cottonwood tree
these things always grow near water
and look at this right down there's a
spring you want to find water in North
America learn how to identify cottonwood
trees from far away
oh that's kind of some nasty water
though
oh oh that hurt oh
yeah nice little Cactus Thorn right in
the top of my foot
yeah you definitely want to wear boots
and long pants around here I've already
pulled a few thorns out of my legs
ouch
oh the desert's not friendly
cool tell you what this place is
deserted I haven't seen a single person
all day
check it out there's some more ruins up
there
on Earth did they get up there though
I'm taking my backpack off of this one
be a pretty good-sized set of ruins here
and these rocks broke off the cliff face
and smashed it
look at this
oh look at this a whole bunch of board
right down there
foreign
there's a room down here sound
look at anastas the Indians Drew this
look at all these drawings
these might be as much as 2 000 years
old
that is so cool look at the little hand
prints they did
look at that I wonder what the rhyme and
reason to this artwork is I mean these
figures don't have heads
but this one's got nipples
look at it and you can see all these
hand prints look at them there's just
tons of them
check out these corn cobs the anasazi's
would grow corn and store it here
look at that that's hundreds of years
old
see this used to be someone's house
right there you can see the mud walls
right down there
it's been like a little Granary or
something there's like all this mud up
here and there's a big pile of corn cobs
I was reading up a little bit on the
history of this place before coming here
and apparently while the last known
occupants of this place around 1200 A.D
there's been people that have been here
for thousands of years prior to that you
see all these big rocks that have fallen
down I bet there was a huge ledge that
was all along here because look there's
paintings all the way up there I can see
lots of drawing of corn stalks and
different people hand prints I think
that's like a turkey or something right
there I have got to get going I am not
making very good time because I keep
stopping and exploring all the time
oh
look at that you could barely tell
that's up there if I hadn't spotted the
petroglyphs in a bit of that wall I
would have never known I wonder how many
of these things have walked right past
look at all these Canyon walls up here
it could be a whole City's hiding up
there that I just missed
oh
that was graceful
oh I think I can see more ruins up there
in the cliffs how on Earth do you get up
there though
I can see it peeking out of that cave
but how do you get up there I think I
need to drop my pack here
oh
foreign
bits of corn
look at that right there that is a very
old piece of bone
another piece of bone
more corn
forget that symbol the line with the
vertical lines coming down from it I saw
that at the other place C mcloyd 1891.
I think at some point graffiti becomes
historic and I think that qualifies
see right there that's a bit of a wall a
little bit of a staircase
a big piece of corn right there
look at that
it's bamboo
where on Earth did they get bamboo from
see some walls right here
check it out you can see all the black
charring on the inside of this wall
probably from all the fires they had in
here to keep them warm in the winter
look at all the black on the ceiling
there must have been another enclosure
here but it's it's all gone
more corn husks
a little Flint flake for making
arrowheads or spear points
that's someone carved a spiral in the
wall
sitting there for hundreds of years
that's crazy you see where snakes
slithered in here slithered out I don't
see any Footprints I don't know the last
time a human being was in here
this is quite A View to have in your
living room look at this
another little cash right in here
oh hey check this out see this
depression right here a thousand years
ago this is how people made flour
just put the cornmeal right in here and
just grind it all up until it's fine
powder
oh check it out there's more over here
I think these Rock slides have buried a
good chunk of this
look at this
oh
I think that's a pack rat skull right
there
all right now for the tricky part I need
to get down
oh
I can't believe I made it up there
all right I consulted my map and I'm in
a little bit of a pickle sun sets in two
and a half hours and I'm about a quarter
of a way through the hike I have stopped
and smelled the roses a bit too much
there's so many interesting things to
see so I need to keep my head down and
make some tracks and it's breaking my
heart a little bit because there are
some ruins right up there on the cliff
and I'm just going past him I can't I
can't stop
right up there in the cliffs I can see
some more ruins oh just don't have
enough time
there's so many side canyons and nooks
and crannies here I could spend a week
exploring all these ruins
hey look a tumbleweed
that's why they call them tumbleweed
see some more ruins in the cave up there
oh
one of these Springs I gotta come back
here with the boys and do this hike
wow that is a girthy tree that's what
the kids call thick that'd be a fun
little campsite right there
oh there's so much stuff up there I'm
missing I'm making good time but at what
cost
I'm making good progress right now but
I've got to keep at it for two good
reasons one is one of the coolest
archaeological sites on this whole hike
it's just up ahead and I want to see it
before the sun goes down in about an
hour and a half and two it's supposed to
start raining after dark tomorrow
so I've got to get out of these washes
before they flood
you can see some small ruins right over
there
right over there and there the other
time to explore looks like there's some
ruins up there too
I could spend days searching this Canyon
there's some really good ruins over here
I gotta check it out just briefly
look at that that is really in good
shape look at the size of that that is
so cool but I've got to get going
I know there's a storm coming tonight
and I can feel it in the wind now the
wind's changed it feels upset
take it out I can see some ruins and
petroglyphs up there okay you go check
them out
yeah we're gonna drop my backpack here
oh
look at that
there's
a little window on
this see a bunch of sticks they put up
vertically together and caked it with
mud
cool
look at this
another little bit of pottery
that is so cool
shards of pottery see where they kind of
made a cool pattern on one side and it's
smooth and concave
that is that is just awesome
we're back I'm glad I made time for this
one but I've got to keep going
got a very tough decision to make not as
far as I want to be I want to go at
least another mile or so before I camp
but this is just the sweetest campsite
ever look at that I even got firewood
already I wouldn't even have to set up
my tent I could just throw down my mat
and my bag and a campfire and this would
be really nice I've got a long way to go
to make my rendezvous with Becca in the
morning
I'd love to stay here but I just don't
think the math adds up I think if I stop
now I'm not going to make it in the
morning
oh that's heartbreaking we need to make
some tracks Before Sunset
there's another set of ruins up here
this one's really special
look at this
look at that piece of pottery
that is so cool look at all these
look at all these pieces of pottery nice
little place to sleep
probably was a roof on that at some
point
look at this
you get a much better feel for what
these houses look like when they were
intact
got the headlight out let's see
twist
we got like a little fireplace right
here in the middle
a little smoke hole at the top a shelf
to foot stuff I can see why somebody
would want this in the desert man this
would be cool in the summer and warm in
the winter
oh
I think we got to do it I think we gotta
go down here
all right
oh I think that's a lot of pack rat
urine and poo
that's really gross they've got these
logs supporting the roof
and all this grass and stuff in between
and check it out they've got a little
hole to let air in when you have a fire
down here
my clock says the sun's gonna set in 20
minutes and it's going to get so dark
and cold in here
it's going to be really hard to find a
campsite in the dark so I gotta make
some tracks all right
we gotta move fast
well I'm back in the wash and I'm a
little bit nervous in about two hours
it's supposed to start raining and that
rain is going to be a mixture of snow
and ice these rocks are going to get
really treacherous and this wash might
fill up with water so one of the reasons
I'm pushing it even though it's getting
dark is I know that every mile I can do
now it's a mile I don't have to do in
the water in the rain
foreign
looks like we gotta climb up some rocks
I've done about four miles since Suds
there and now I'm just climbing out of
the canyon Just One Last push I get up
on the plateau and then I'm gonna find a
spot in Camp all right I made it and I
found a nice flat spot
you know I was feeling pretty warm until
I stopped moving now I'm getting really
cold I think it's time to make some warm
dinner
get into bed
[Music]
hot and toasty chunk of gouda cheese
that is hard to beat
oh that's good it is getting cold
oh I've been looking forward to a hot
meal all day
hit the spot
oh my shoulders are sore from holding
that backpack now I brought my water
filter and we had so many chances to
fill up on Water I just didn't think I
needed to and I was I was in a hurry now
this is my last gulp of water
who knows maybe it'll rain enough to to
fill up my uh my water pot we're gonna
put my little cooking pot out here and
see if we can't catch some rain
well I am exhausted guys I did a lot of
hiking
my sleeping bag is inside out
but man I want to go to sleep
and uh
and call it a night yeah
oh good morning well the rain was pretty
decent last night and it turned into
snow at some point because I could hear
the snow sliding off the roof of the
tent so I'm a little curious to see what
it looks like outside
oh got a bit of snow and rain in my pot
so I got some water for breakfast this
morning yay
foreign
moderately warm instant oatmeal on a
winter compound this reminds me of
camping as a kid so much
it's really not that good
all right
we're gonna make a cup of tea and wash
out my cup all with the same water
because water is a precious commodity
here
[Music]
nothing like being out in the woods
enjoying a cup of hot tea while watching
Star Trek the Next Generation on your
phone
I think I better start cleaning up my
stuff all right
uh we got Camp broke down now we need to
go find the PATH it's somewhere over
here but you can see with the snow makes
things tricky
well I pushed hard last night and did
about four and a half miles in the dark
and I am really glad I did that
I'm in really easy Striking Distance to
make my rendezvous with Becca this
morning and I am really glad to not be
hiking on that slick Rock in the snow
and I'm really glad that it's snowing
instead of raining freezing rain is the
worst it is the absolute worst I'll take
negative 20 over freezing rain
we got fresh deer tracks
those must have been this morning
there's only a little bit of snow in
them
I made it and most importantly I didn't
keep my wife waiting
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you guys want to see more videos like
this check out our playlist we have
entire camping Adventure playlist and
then I have a bunch of hiking Adventure
playlists as well so I'll put links to
those playlists in the video description
below and if you want to see more videos
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
click subscribe because we put out
videos every Saturday morning all right
I'll see you next Saturday take care
[Music]
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]